third question today David how would you
feel about instituting required military
service but also giving people the
option of doing some kind of organized
national service instead of serving you
know I would not be against mandatory
service of some kind for everybody
regardless of economic background
regardless of regardless of all factors
my concern in the United States would be
that we would screw it up big time right
because there are lots of places I mean
look say what you want about Israel's
foreign policy Israel has a mandatory
service which I think is I think he used
to be three years for men and two years
for women I think it might have been
reduced to two years for men in a year
and a half for women where you do basic
training everybody does it you become
trained in sort of military basics etc
you can say very clearly very early on
I'm sort of like a pacifist or I object
to really going in the direction of
being being trained for a military
conflict because I wouldn't participate
in it period and you can work in a
hospital
you can work in social service you can
work in a lot of other areas which I
would argue almost even aside from the
military what about just mandatory
social service of some kind for people
ideologically I'm ok with it in practice
in the United States I'd be really
concerned that we screw it up and it
leads to further militarization of the
country which is the absolute last thing
that we need in the United States and
also it is basically the reinstituting
of a draft so because of the history of
the United States as having had a draft
and then getting rid of the draft even
if you're creating something different
now where the idea is military service
or some kind of national or social
service because of the history of the
United States I think it would be really
problematic sort of emotionally for the
country so I think that I'm up for the
idea of this being done in countries in
general in some amorphous way but I
think there's no way to do it now in the
United States and not have just a
disastrous situation yeah I think I
would be against mandatory service
because it sounds like big government
and I don't really want to
would force people who are like 18 19
years old into doing something like this
oh my goodness but I think what would
work is making something like joining
the Peace Corps for a year joining
AmeriCorps or getting involved in the
military for one year or two a
prerequisite to get into college so
private and public universities across
the country have this universally
agreed-upon system by which those who
apply have to have spent one year or W
in some sort of service I think does a
little bit more sense you said you don't
like the big government idea of the
government forcing you to do these
things wouldn't the government have to
force the private colleges to adopt the
policy No
so you're citing college now the public
colleges colleges could choose not to
adopt it yeah and it defeats the purpose
of your idea a little bit but maybe it's
just like you know like that you send in
your grades from your high school and
you have to meet a certain benchmark in
order to get in yeah and maybe you have
to get extracurriculars in order to get
to an elite school or even a public
college this should be one of those
things I think interesting that that
might be an interesting way of
implementing it I think though that if
you actually want it to be universal and
not just public colleges you've got to
force the private ones to do it which is
not that there could be some exceptions
I think yeah we'll work through it
together after the about it yeah after
the show we'll talk about it great
questions this week send your questions
in to me via Twitter I'm on Twitter at
Dee Pakman we've got a great bonus show
for you today
and we are off on Monday Pat don't come
in on Monday I've been telling Pat for
weeks he keeps talking about Mondays
show and I'm like do not come in here
because I won't be here for Memorial Day
but we will be back on Tuesday or
today's bonus show which is really
really great